saki won't say whether hunter biden has
divested from chinese private equity
firm or not
uh
did i say page id yeah white house press
secretary genesecy on monday refused to
say whether president biden's son hunter
has divested his 10 stake in the chinese
equity from the firm despite the
president's pledge to prohibit family
members from engaging in international
business dealings chinese business
records reviewed by fox news indicate
hundred biden still holds 10 stake in
one chinese private equity firm this
comes after their decade then candidate
joe biden said in october 2019 that his
family would not
engage in business dealings with other
countries overseas hunters previously
sat on the chinese firm's board before
announcing in october 2019 that he would
be stepping down from mounting scrutiny
from his father's presidential bid i
actually want to know how sacky answered
this question can you pull up
exactly what she said in here if you
have it
uh i want to know what that exchange
sounded like was it like blowing you off
or was it actually an answer
that's not saying
about uh
hunter biden let me see how this was
uh
don't imagine what china has on hunter
biden can you imagine the blackmail that
they have on joe biden and hunter biden
like
this dude is like a lie he's fredo
right like i mean he's fredo corleone
he's not saying the exact same thing
that they that they the liberals said
about
trump and russia i would say bush's
daughters would be closer to hunter
biden but that's even like that's really
disrespecting his daughters this is her
this guy's a he's a massive drug addict
this is her answer her answer is i'd
point you to his representative on that
he doesn't work in the administration
and then
again i convey to you and then i think
i'm going to have to move on that you
should talk to his representatives saki
said in february that hunter was in the
process of unloading his shares in
february he has been working to unwind
his investment but i would certainly
point you
uh uh he is a private citizen i would
point you to him or his lawyers on the
outside on any update so she said in
october in february that this was going
to happen now she's just avoiding this
saying it's not my job she's not part of
the administration
go look elsewhere
you know
as a voter do you think that you know
gets get somebody that voted a voter for
them to say yeah i really don't care
like does that change your mind about
biden's vote in 2024. are you kind of
like oh my gosh i can't believe this has
happened it's going to change my way of
voting i've been pretty clear i could
care less about hunter briden
i'm glad that he's not
like if he was involved in the
administration
alarm bells will be going off but he's a
private citizen he's a drug addict i'm
sure he's done some shady stuff but
thank god he's not in the room with
biden making any decisions that's not
that's not true though did the
babalinski stuff back in back when the
election was was rounding in the form
did that bother you at all
that turned out not to be true that that
story would like was bobolinsky was the
guy who came on the the news tucker
carlson turned out it was 100 it was
very verified by multiple sources i
don't know literally does nothing for
the emails the big guy gets 10 percent
with i do say that kai does take 10
that's something that he jokes about a
lot
you know what i just i don't think that
the hunt i think my sisters couldn't
care less either no matter how many
times i tried explaining to them like
what a national security threat this was
what a liability this was to the
national security united states they
they could not care less advice to the
right-wing media pushing the hunter
media hunter biden stuff down the throat
people that
they just don't care
like if they they just don't like you
can argue why you should
it's it's almost like i didn't care when
eric does it
does he feel like a low blow does it
feel like a low blow
a house like going after a guy's family
a guy you know
i think it's fair game but if you're
doing that with like why would you vote
for this man hunter bite and smoke crack
it's like okay but it's it's the it's
the does nothing for me the blackmail
but the same thing
when they would make fun of eric trump
all the time i was like baron
i don't care like
listen everyone has family bill
clinton's brother was a weirdo obama's
brother can like i tend to agree with
you like like
like people are gonna have people in
their family and i didn't like her what
was the the woman from alaska i didn't
like her at all sarah palin her daughter
and daughter the daughter had a
handicapped kid that was horrible leave
the family out but this is different i i
if this is different specifically
because okay he was illegally selling
access and i'm totally cool with the
press finding out what the hell's going
on i'm not saying leave him alone
but unless it's actually something
shocking and
like reveals something that actually
compromises joe biden in fact then all
right i don't think most people care
does the hunter buy stuff bother you at
all or no
i'm so confused right now
uh so so this guy
is doing business with the number one
enemy that doesn't do nothing to you and
it's the son of the president yeah i
don't know about that bro so so you
forget that a guy is doing business with
the number one enemy i'm not so cool
with the china thing who would that
should be enough that's that's that's uh
that's the issue
so you're the your father is the
president of the united states
and your son is doing business with
china and there's dealing with anything
with china i'm not cool with yeah i'll
say that all i'm saying to you is if
you're linked
replacing they're making him out to be
some sort of like global henchman
businessman he's like some crackhead
dude but but she's trying to make money
listen and i get that you can be
compromised let me let me
let me give a different perspective how
regulated is the securities industry
very right okay so let's just say i'm
doing a business deal and i i funnel the
money through
uh a non-licensed securities person
who's really bringing the business in
and it's wink wink don't worry about it
but you're doing business that's that
all the time so that's what's going on
here except they dictate china's
dictating a lot of the deals okay so
they can pay this guy he should be held
accountable who should be held
accountable
if he's doing something illegal then
bring some charges against him but it's
linked to his father and his father's
your president forget forget about i'm
not even concerned about joe biden if if
hunter biden is doing something illegal
bring some charges against him you're
not hearing like money doesn't funnel
like that money's funneling through
a guy's here hey i need a favor from
this guy can you do this and i give you
the money and you make the phone call
and that guy you know there's so let me
let me throw something here because
obviously i know you you tend to agree
with donald trump on things when
everything was coming out that
uh donald trump jr was taking these
meetings and made these phone calls it
was fake and russia
and
it was fake it was verified russell
brand a guy on the far left who came out
and talked about a lot of we care less
what russell branson has because it
doesn't favor your argument what was
fake exactly no he actually the whole
dossier was a funded by hillary clinton
yeah so the what but there were meetings
with russia when trump went out there
like you're saying that what meetings
would russia you're saying that was what
meetings would russia
that russia had zero help uh with uh
with anything oh wait wait wait are you
saying that trump had russia help him on
the election i'm not saying that i'm
saying but russia did those are two
different things bro no no no no no no
you can't say something when stories are
out and here's my question no stories
they're out in the news u.s is involved
in all the elections they tamper every
country does powerful tampers and other
but there's a difference to say help me
out okay versus a person individually
independently doesn't it that's not the
same thing my question to you is when
news was because this is news to me news
here one day out the other when news was
out there about
donald trump jr eric trump or divesting
of their companies they're compromised
at that point four years ago we were
like well you know they should look into
it they should oh no no let me tell you
what let me tell you what i was thinking
about it right my mind went to this if
this is true it's game over for his
entire family's legacy
if any of that is stuff is true trump is
using america to make money okay if any
of that is true you're using america to
make money and that's where i'm at well
but it is
i don't know if it's true
what i'm saying is bring some charges
you remember the new york post story
that was supposed to be posted that
everything was shut down and five days
later they're like you can put it up and
that one new york post story that was
going viral was blocked all over twitter
why right before the election why what
happened
of course not
seriously
we talked about on the podcast
you know what i like about you let me
tell you what i like about you know the
movie you know the movie what's the
goldfish movie what is that one the dory
dory is the one that's got the memory
yeah
one of the best qualities of shooters is
amnesia
you got a good memory i don't know
what's on the laptop let me just let me
just say one thing you know how many
times i wake up and think even think
about hunter biden zero why not and most
people don't because there's so many
other things that's going on in life
that i gotta think about hunter biden
why not if he's doing some illegal
bring some charges against them would
you have this well you want me to like
run down every rabbit hole because you
mentioned hunter peyton's name
it's annoying okay what about the laptop
what are your thoughts on tell me what's
on the laptop i don't know about the
laptop show me some hands on the laptop
what do you do on the laptop all i've
heard for the last year is hunter bite
and hunter bite and arthur buying what
do you
what do you do
bring some charges they're trying to
they're trying to get the media to cover
the laptop they're trying to get the
media to cover these stories so that you
can be aware of it i hate this and it's
being surprised trying to get the media
as if the right doesn't have media news
max isn't out there one fox missus
doesn't we just covered the first story
that fox news gets more viewers than
anyone else yeah the media the media fox
news is the media yeah that's exactly
right so it comes up tell your friends
at fox news to start covering the story
so
2.5 million people a night know exactly
what we're talking about it's the other
three million that are living in an
opposite reality that we're trying to
convince that these things that are
facts are facts right so just because
hannity says that it's not a fact
i'm not a hannity guy yeah you are i'm
not a handy guy i'm going to paint you
as well hey have you ever did you ever
read a robert smalling's book stealth
war
did you ever read that uh no
there's a few there's a few parts in
there that i think you would be very
interested in and it's pertaining to the
relationship that hunter biden actually
has okay um i i definitely think fyi
it's not just the left it's both of them
mcconnell's also on the right all the
connections to china so his wife is
chinese this is more the issue
but my point is this yeah even when we
talked about what's her name elizabeth
wu yeah is that her name i just make
that
what's up
what's mcconnell's wife's name
even when they've told stories about her
it doesn't do nothing for me and i'm not
a mcconnell fan but i'm not going to go
down the rabbit hole of like well yep
mcconnell's compromised
there it is yeah but the figurehead
that concerns me
it should concern you yeah but unless
he's they've proven that he's done
something illegal it's just a story in
the news did the general military stuff
bother you at all or no
let me ask you a question when's the
last time when's the last time serious
question though when's the last time you
said like you remember the scene where
uh uh the day uh giuliani took down like
245 you know mobsters got arrested or
joe piston and you saw all of them
handcuffed walking out when's the last
time you saw that happening to
congressmen and senators
do you know why it's never happened do
you think it's because they've never
broken the law
because they created
can you imagine that scene how come
that's never happened but have you seen
have you seen pastors or priests going
through handcuffs and going to jail yeah
have you seen mobsters have you seen
athletes have you seen business people
have you seen the only industry that
apparently we've never seen that before
is politicians well how does that make
any sense some yeah so they're they're
the angels they're the angels they're
not all that's what they're not at all
yeah
on the left or the right of course
this is not a politician once did we say
left or right this is politician
who's not a politician his father is i
get it he funnels his deals through his
son
he's the bad guy he funnels deals
through his son
sammy the good boy carvano told me he
says john's never killed anybody alexis
says i don't care if john's ever killed
anybody
he said it's not the person that kills
them it's the person that orders other
people to kill them that he says sammy
says i've he says he's got four that he
took out or whatever the numbers that
he's got out of his 19 he says the rest
i ordered somebody else to do the hit
right so it's not him doing it so it's
not not necessarily biting doing the
work but he's got somebody else's
shadier has done shadier things more
things that are illegal trump or biden
not even close you think it's biden do
you know why tell me why because if you
do it in business you eventually get
caught and go to jail
that's why that's why
but in politics you know did you not
hear me three minutes ago
in business you eventually get caught
you can't fight it you eventually get
caught in business you you can skirt the
laws for sure
no no skirt the laws is fine i don't
disagree with skirt you can play in the
great yeah but well he said that he did
but politicians can play in the black
white grey blue green purple whatever
the hell they want to do because they
create the laws that's why we need a
clean house anyone over 70 needs to be
out of politics this isn't about seven
it doesn't take seven years to learn bad
habits it doesn't take seven years to
learn bad habits clean house you just
need to go to the right environment we
go to jail what happens when people go
to jail what do people call jail
training ground to produce more
criminals in other words okay you go to
politics you're like i'm going to be a
statesman i love america
i'm going to do such great things
hey do you know if we give you two
hundred thousand dollars right there i'm
gonna get two hundred thousand dollar
sketch of course just to everybody does
it okay and then johnny cash movie just
take it everybody does it you know walk
the line yeah that's the training ground
for producing people that know how to
abuse
have you ever interviewed a lobbyist
have you ever had like somebody who was
an actor i have a very close friend of
mine
that's a
i can't say his name that's a very
powerful lobbyist
for a long time that he left the
business
and he's he tells me stuff okay i will
never re he tells me stuff and he says
pat as dirty as you think as it is
he says it's a million times dirty he
says you don't even know how dirty it is
and how to negotiate with each other he
says you don't even know how they
negotiate with us like what things we
get you don't even know if the lobby
left the game and they could not exist
it'd be a very different world today the
people that would win office would be
very different people if you didn't have
lobbyists and if you couldn't take
campaign there's a lot of different
things you can change what's a dirty
word we have to explain one day what
the actual way our government works now
with lobbyists and if anybody out there
wants to know like what a lobbyist is
and really and explain kind of my time
in government watch thank you for
smoking i'll give a plug for a
phenomenal movie watch thank you for
stopping phenomenal yeah
it's uh you know it's it it's amazing
how accurate that was
yeah and they they hang out in the state
house i can only imagine what it's like
uh you know at a federal level but they
hang out in the state house from the
chamber to your office is fair game so
these guys you try to run from the
chamber so you know the the session will
break and all the elected officials
they'll leave the chamber and then the
lobbyists like cockroaches they they
swarm and they try to get their mark
before they get to their office so that
that walk down the hall is like insane
and that's where all the action it's all
illegal it's all legal
all right having said that it's 7 37
sometimes we should get cameras and like
microphones in those halls yeah right
just it's a fair game it's very good
you've been a lobbyist sit down with pat
on a pbd interview like we just did like
like you just did with the guy from
facebook we need to get like like an
insider series going here so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]